There's nothing quite like the anticipation
of a multi-mega-million-dollar movie making
its theatrical debut… and nothing like the
agony of watching it go down in flames.
Not every big-budget Hollywood blockbuster
makes bank at the box office, and sometimes,
studios guess wrong about what will and will
not perform.
Here are some of the films that have been
surprising disappointments.
47 Ronin
With a large budget, a reliable kung fu fighter
as its star, and a plot that included both
samurais and dragons, 47 Ronin was supposed
to be the kind of action-packed blockbuster
that makes for a reliable end-of-year hit.
Unfortunately, the behemoth of a movie turned
out to be too unwieldy for its first-time
director, Carl Rinsch.
Plagued by problems and requiring extensive
reshoots, it was delayed by more than a year—and
despite the biggest, best Christmas push the
studio could muster, 47 Ronin only made $38
million in the US, far short of its $175 million
budget.
John Carter
The insanely high expectations for this tragic
bomb of a movie may just be one of Hollywood's
great mysteries—because in hindsight, its
belly-flop at the box office should've been
a foregone conclusion.
Taylor Kitsch was a popular cast member on
Friday Night Lights prior to being cast as
John Carter's main character, but he was hardly
a bankable star for a $250 million dollar
space opera.
But that's exactly what Disney did—and the
problems were compounded by one of the most
grossly mishandled marketing campaigns in
the history of cinema.
Ultimately, John Carter was an earth-shattering
disappointment that left the studio with a
whopping $177 million dollar loss in the US
before turning a small profit internationally.
Still, it wasn't enough to keep the too-hopeful
franchise afloat.
Battleship
The "you sunk my Battleship" jokes write themselves
when it comes to this $300 million albatross.
Battleship had all the makings of a big summer
blockbuster, with a cast of well-muscled dudes
steering the ship, and high hopes of leveraging
the same '80s-kid nostalgia that made the
Transformers franchise such a giant moneymaker.
"Missiles good to go, let's light 'em up."
But at the box office, Battleship suffered
from stiff competition from The Avengers,
bad press, and a bad reputation for leading
man Taylor Kitsch, who you might remember
from his mention 55 seconds ago.
Although the movie made back its production
budget once it hit international waters, it
still left Universal taking an $83 million
dollar bath.
"Negative sir, it's a miss."
The Lone Ranger
Before Johnny Depp's personal reputation started
to sour, his professional presence was supposed
to be a reliable predictor of a film's success.
So, with him sharing the lead, Disney pegged
The Lone Ranger movie as a big moneymaker
at the outset, pumping north of $215 million
into the production.
But even once it became clear that The Lone
Ranger wasn't going to break any box office
records, its ultimate losses were wildly unexpected.
The film ultimately didn't even make back
half of its budget in the US due to dismal
audience interest.
"Okay, don't come see if I care."
The cast and crew blamed unfair reviews for
quashing ticket sales, but others pointed
to the whitewashing and stereotyping of its
Native American character Tonto as troublesome.
"Perhaps you want to make it look like Comanche
violated treaty."
Ender's Game
Based on a classic science fiction novel by
Orson Scott Card, set in outer space, and
with a cast that included up-and-comer Asa
Butterfield and everyone's favorite star warrior
Harrison Ford, Ender's Game was a movie with
seriously high hopes.
But despite the box-office promise of a big-budget
movie about teen soldiers battling hostile
aliens while the fate of the earth hangs in
the balance, Ender's Game was plagued by issues,
including the effects of a boycott from groups
who were angered by the author's stance on
same-sex marriage.
Between the bad press stemming from that and
mixed reviews from critics, it ended up barely
recouping its $115 million budget.
Fantastic Four
After a slightly cheesy but successful pair
of Fantastic Four films rocked the box office
in the early 2000s, a fresh round of films
featuring Marvel's first family seemed like
just the thing for an up-and-coming director.
Josh Trank, who'd done great things with the
found-footage thriller Chronicle, was tapped
to helm the pic, with a promising young cast
in tow.
Producers were counting on the foursome to
become the next big thing in superhero ensembles,
alongside the X-Men and the Avengers.
What they weren't counting on, unfortunately,
was for Trank to clash with the studio and
behave so erratically on set that Fox felt
compelled to reshoot huge portions of the
movie after the fact.
The finished product was ghastly by all accounts…
which makes it unsurprising that the film
took in only $26.2 million on its opening
weekend and $168 million worldwide, against
an estimated $200 million production and marketing
budget.
Jupiter Ascending
After The Matrix, everyone was on pins and
needles to find out what wild new world the
Wachowskis had cooked up with Jupiter Ascending.
The film had all the ingredients of success,
including two of the coolest kids in Hollywood,
Mila Kunis and Channing Tatum, in the lead.
This story of a cleaning lady who learns she's
the heir apparent to an intergalactic empire
had the full force and faith of big money
behind it, to the tune of a $176 million production
budget.
"And you begged me to do it."
But the Wachowskis reportedly overspent on
the film, test audiences were unimpressed,
and the critical reception was extremely chilly—all
adding up to a worldwide take of $184 million
that didn't compensate for the massive budget
and marketing costs of the picture.
Mars Needs Moms
If you've never heard of Mars Needs Moms...
lucky you!
The name is a pun of "Mars Needs Women" a
60's Sci-Fi b-movie that was just as bad as
this one.
On paper, it had all the makings of a hit,
including fresh visuals thanks to advanced
motion-capture technology, and a family-bonding
plotline with a cool alien twist.".
But nobody could've anticipated what an unmitigated
disaster the release would be.
Not counting the cost of marketing, Mars Needs
Moms cost $150 million to make —and even
with international ticket sales, its total
revenue was just shy of $39 million, making
this film a planet-sized flop for Disney.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!